[Musique]
Joséphine Goldman berger bonjour bonjour
alors nous sommes chez vous à Plaisir
d'où vous êtes merde dans ce magnifique
théâtre Coluche et alors là on est en
train de il montage du spectacle
Lawrence d'Arabie exactement qui va être
capté ici exactement capter ici et ça on
en est très très fier d'abord c'est un
très beau spectacle et puis le fait
d'avoir choisi plaisir c'est bien
voilà c'est le théâtre de votre ville de
plaisir mais là je reçois plutôt la
vice-président du conseil départemental
en charge la Culture et du Tourisme et
on va parler de culture de la politique
départementale de la culture parce que
on s'y retrouve pas forcément très bien
entre savoir quelles sont les
compétences des villes quelles sont les
compétences des communautés
d'agglomération et du département c'est
quoi la politique culturelle d'un
département c'est vrai que c'est
complexe pour pour les artistes et même
pour la population puis finalement la
population ce qu'elle veut c'est que il
y a de la culture sur le département et
fonctionne bien alors le département
c'est priorités c'est bien sûr son
public le département a des compétences
particulières et des axes particuliers
qui sont surtout je dirais les les
familles les personnes en difficulté
c'est à dire tout ce qui est social la
politique de la ville mais également les
collèges on a énormément je dirais
d'accompagnement à faire dans ces
domaines-là et c'est vrai que le
département au niveau de la culture se
penche là dessus c'est à dire que nos
partenaires nous sont là pour nous
accompagner pour un petit peu infiltré
l'ensemble du département ce qui est
important à savoir c'est que nous avons
mis en place maintenant il y a de
nombreuses années des appels à projets
qui déterminent notre feuille de route
parce que ce qui est important justement
parce que vous lisiez c'est
qu'aujourd'hui comment on fait pour se
repérer alors la feuille de route de
l'État et pas la même au niveau culturel
que celle du département exactement il y
a l'étape il y a les villes les villes
aussi leurs feuilles de route et donc
nous on est orienté justement vers nos
qu'à nous et les appellent à projets que
nous avons créés vont dans ce sens-là et
aujourd'hui on essaie bien sûr de
motiver l'ensemble de nos partenaires et
ça marche bien il faut le dire oui quand
vous dites c'est vrai que la
préoccupation sociale des départements
est très forte il y a une dimension
sociale dans la politique culturelle ah
oui elle est très importante puisque
nous nous allons au devant des publics
dit empêcher nous allons également vers
les seniors nous allons également
pourquoi pas aussi vers les prisons
c'est à dire que il y a toute une
population qui est très éloignée de la
culture et c'est notre rôle à nous et
bien de les accompagner et les artistes
ont ouvert à tout ça jusqu'aujourd'hui
on voit bien des artistes qui vont dans
les prisons dans les EHPAD dans les
hôpitaux et puis bien sûr dans les
collèges c'est sûr donc on les
accompagne un autre public enfin qui
était un peu exclu de la exactement
très riche culturellement on va en
parler parce qu'on va voir un peu les
événements qui vont se produire et puis
les efforts que vous faites alors
d'abord il y a une richesse patrimoniale
c'est pas par hasard si si Charles III
vient à Versailles c'est clair oui alors
il paraît peut-être pas il va peut-être
venir à Paris moi j'ai enfin bon on
verra oui en tout cas la richesse
patrimoniale de ce département est très
forte mais évidemment on parle toujours
du château de Versailles il y a pas que
Versailles il y a beaucoup d'autres
choses là par exemple il y a de il y a
eu des rénovations comme la maison de
Zola bien sûr intégralement et la maison
de Zola a même vu le président de la
République
visiter cet endroit qui est un endroit
vraiment
réhabilitée grâce aux aides
départementales mais on a beaucoup de
maisons d'illustre importante puis on a
aussi notre musée Maurice Denis à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui était qui est
rouvert qui a été aussi remis en état
avec plusieurs millions d'euros grâce au
département qui aujourd'hui est un lieu
bien sûr d'exposition permanente mais
aussi d'exposition qui change
régulièrement et aussi avec un parc dans
lequel il y a beaucoup d'animations on
se retrouve avec un musée qui est connu
de façon internationale puisque
aujourd'hui nous prêtons même des œuvres
dans le monde entier dans le monde
entier oui donc on a des vrais lieux
très importants
[Musique]
veut faire de sa vie de la ville de la
toile quoi c'est la toile de Jouy c'est
avec le musée de jouir
ma collègue qui est vraiment
exceptionnelle qui a aussi été
complètement réhabilité puisque nous en
avons nous avons fait l'inauguration de
ce nouveau site il y a quelques mois
vraiment d'une qualité vraiment
exceptionnelle et là aussi c'est très
international parce que les personnes
qui viennent à Versailles ont parlé du
château mais font aussi un détour pour
aller voir le musée de la toile de Jouy
donc c'est plutôt valorisant pour notre
territoire et c'est vrai qu'il y a oui
cet attachement enfin
il y a une identité quoi de des Yvelines
certaines villes du département à ce
patrimoine culturel
on a des on a des démarches et des
actions et des appels à projets très
forts sur le patrimoine puisque le
département a déclenché toute une série
d'actions d'accompagnement sur le
patrimoine et surtout au niveau du rural
puisque vous savez les petites communes
aujourd'hui ont des vrais difficultés et
donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec des
mères qui nous appellent pour qu'on
puisse les accompagner pour parc leur
église s'effondre
maculaire exactement et on a une
accompagnement de plusieurs millions et
et à chaque commission permanente ou à
chaque conseil départemental on présente
des projets qui accompagnent les
collectivités là-dessus et c'est
vraiment important est-ce que mon ami
Stéphane Bern
[Musique]
vous êtes un peu parce que nous on va
lui
dire davantage davantage il peut le
faire il peut le faire davantage il y a
un endroit qui est peut-être moins connu
qui qui est assez formidable c'est le
donjon ou dans oui qui est très alors
j'ai eu la chance de le visiter et je
trouve ça très intéressant parce que il
y a un mélange de l'ancien et du et du
moderne et du contemporain avec des
mélanges de couleurs un peu un peu forte
c'est très très beau ce qui a été fait
et en plus qui a été fait dans le cadre
de la réhabilitation et ben du
centre-ville et donc ça je trouve que
c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée très très
beau monument effectivement et puis il y
a des collaborations entre le public et
le privé je pense au château de
Dampierre par exemple qui est appartient
privé oui il y a une famille vieille
famille mais là aussi vous intergissez
avec oui le département des Yvelines est
vraiment je dirais dans un dans un
développement de partenariat que ce soit
avec le public les collectivités mais
également le privé quand il y a une
nécessité vraiment importante de
reconnaissance à la fois patrimoniale et
touristique le département en règle
générale répond présent donc
on est là on est là oui on est là alors
ça c'est le patrimoine pour promouvoir
historique plutôt il y a un autre
patrimoine qui est un patrimoine
culturel ce sont les grandes scènes
nationales il y a de scènes de Grande
Scène nationale et celle de
Saint-Quentin et celle de Sartrouville
la clé justement alors ça c'est l'état
c'est la région c'est le département il
y a un peu tout le monde et même les
collectivités
locales oui alors là on a vraiment des
exemples je dirais de partenariats des
différentes possibilités de subventions
et d'aide puisque vous l'avez dit c'est
tout à fait ça le théâtre de
Saint-Quentin est aidé effectivement par
l'État la région et le département et la
ville aussi et une scène nationale c'est
très important sur un territoire parce
que ils ont un cahier des charges très
précis par rapport à la création et par
rapport aussi à tout ce qui doivent
faire et accompagner sur le territoire
Sartrouville c'est un peu la même chose
avec des aides aussi très diverses mais
il y a le festival odyssée
festival très important pour les jeunes
pour les jeunes ce sont plusieurs
centaines de représentations qui sont
faites dans l'ensemble des Yvelines
autour de création faites au niveau du
Théâtre de Sartrouville c'est pour ça
qu'il y a une aide particulière et je
vous en cite un autre c'est la barbacane
de ben oui parce que la barbacane moins
connu par scène nationale non plus mais
c'est un théâtre qui aujourd'hui apporte
énormément de d'actions aussi
culturelles sur un territoire qui est
beaucoup plus rural et donc là on a
trouvé tout à fait naturel que le
département puisse les accompagner au
même titre que les scènes nationales
juste un mot parce que il va y avoir des
travaux
à Saint-Quentin au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin et je discutais avec la
directrice de du théâtre Coluche vous
allez récupérer si je peux dire ce
nouveau pas très joli mais vous allez
faire des spectacles qui auraient dû
être de 50 ans ils vont avoir lieu dans
ce théâtre Coluche oui
et dans d'autres dans d'autres
et c'est très bien ça prouve le
partenariat il a transversalité entre
les différents acteurs du territoire ça
démontre bien qu'on travaille ensemble
ça démontre que on peut tout à fait je
dirais avoir des des projets communs et
donc on est très fier effectivement
d'accords
important c'est celui des festivals il y
a de grands festivals dans les Yvelines
il y a pour commencer par peut-être de
festival de cirque des bureaux qui est
un succès ça considérable alors je peux
en parler d'autant plus que j'y suis
allée à la dernière au dernier spectacle
c'est extraordinaire oui vraiment et
c'est pour ça que nous l'accompagnons
assez fortement depuis plusieurs années
c'est vraiment un spectacle de cirque de
très très haut niveau aussi sont des
artistes presque enfin pas presse ce
sont des artistes internationaux qui
viennent avec un concours et surtout
sublime et c'est ce qui nous intéresse
hormis la qualité c'est le fait que
c'est familial et donc vous avez vous
avez un chapiteau rempli de famille et
d'enfants et tout ça aux portes du
quartier en politique de la ville des
Mureaux et on ne peut pas ne pas y être
on est obligé d'être des partenaires de
ce festival moi j'ai un enthousiasme fou
pour ça j'étais très émue d'aller là-bas
et de voir je dirais cet engouement
complètement complètement
c'est quoi les étoiles de Saint-Germain
c'est ce sont des des jeunes oui c'est
du classique alors là c'est de la
musique classique et ce sont des jeunes
qui
essaient de se faire connaître par le
biais justement de d'un développement
musical c'est quelque chose qui est
assez récent sur notre territoire mais
que nous avons souhaité accompagner
parce que il y a aussi un intérieur des
personnes handicapées qui interviennent
au niveau de ce festival donc c'est
quelque chose qui a très bien fonctionné
on continue le développement de ce cadre
là on est complètement ailleurs mais oui
complètement mais il y a des publics
différents il y a des vies différentes
il y a des des aspirations différentes
c'est tout à fait normal c'est large la
culture et en même temps on essaie de
d'amener le cirque aussi à Saint-Germain
et la musique classique
le but du début c'est ça c'est que tout
ce mélange
un peu particulier mais j'aimerais bien
que vous nous en parler un petit peu
c'est le festival et le hall oui
qui est dans la région de menthe c'est
ça
c'est le c'est le voilà c'est de là
aussi la sauvegarde du patrimoine un peu
c'est ça ça c'est un festival qui de
longue date ça fait des années qu'il
existe c'est quelque chose c'est un
festival qui entraîne énormément de de
de
d'acteurs locaux donc il y a un vrai une
vraie reconnaissance aussi patrimoniale
par rapport à ce festival là c'est un
quelque chose d'important il faut y
aller il faut absolument y aller il faut
y aller je vais y aller
alors on ira
évidemment il y a alors
éloigné d'agriculture mais pas forcément
la perspective des Jeux Olympiques en
2024 avec beaucoup d'épreuves sur le
dans les Yvelines enfin
Versailles vers Saint-Quentin
est-ce que justement en quoi la culture
est intéressée par les JO et peut rendre
compte de de cet événement c'est bien
que vous me posiez cette question parce
que quand on a sorti cet appel à projet
sur justement ce qu'on appelle les les
Olympiades culturelles tout le monde
nous disait mais quel rapport avec la
culture et tout ça en vérité ça le
rapport est dans les valeurs de
l'olympisme les valeurs de l'olympisme
sont exactement les valeurs que nous
journaux au niveau de la culture c'est à
dire cet échange la transversalité
l'empathie l'ouverture à l'autre
l'ouverture vers les difficultés des uns
et des autres donc on a mis le mot
Olympia de certes parce que on a des
actions interculturelles et sportives
certes c'est vrai mais en tout cas cette
appel à projeter sur les valeurs donc on
est on est dans un cadre très large des
Jeux Olympiques on va au-delà du Sud
exactement aujourd'hui ça y est tout le
monde a commencé à comprendre puisque
les dossiers que nous recevons
aujourd'hui sont complètement je dirais
en adéquation avec cette ouverture là et
un mot sur ces appels à projets parce
que c'est important de savoir comment ça
ça fonctionne c'est vous définissez le
thème par exemple les Olympiades c'est
ça oui et donc c'est des troubles des
acteurs culturels qui
donnent des projets qui vous donne des
projets c'est ça exactement on a
plusieurs appels à projets dont celui-ci
et donc après c'est ouvert à tout le
monde ça peut être une collectivité ça
peut être une association ça peut être
un théâtre ça peut être chacun dans le
cadre de ses actions peut nous proposer
un appel à projet qui correspond à la
thématique en règle générale il y a des
appels à projets qui sont récurrents et
puis il y a des appels à projets comme
celui-ci qui est plutôt je dirais dans
le temps évidemment et donc ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que et ça je
voudrais vraiment le dire avec force
c'est que très souvent la compréhension
des appels à projets semble parfois un
peu complexe et je voudrais le dire les
services du département sont vraiment à
disposition de nos partenaires pour les
rencontrer leur expliquer
je suis pas du dire mais leur tenir la
main presque pour leur dire attendez
allons plutôt dans ce sens là vous êtes
voilà et on est vraiment là pour ça vous
savez on a on a des budgets qui sont
déterminés chaque année et ces budgets
le but c'est de les distribuer en
intelligence avec notre feuille de route
mais c'est de les distribuer donc on
n'est pas là en train de les tenir avec
nos petits bras musclés donc ce qu'on
veut c'est rencontrer les partenaires et
leur dire bon ben voilà on vous
accompagne au maximum donc il faut
vraiment qu'ils viennent nous voir
et c'est vrai que il y a des équipes
formidables qui travaillent au conseil
départemental
merci de le dire j'en suis vraiment très
heureuse allez pour conclure presque si
on disait voilà les à votre avis quels
sont les quatre ou cinq évènements qu'il
faudrait pas rater cette année oh là là
alors je vais faire déjà
oui c'est embêtant parce on va essayer
on a voilà puis surtout dans des lieux
un petit peu différents parce que c'est
important oui on a on a on a
Lectro saga ça c'est quelque chose qui
qui existe depuis très très longtemps et
c'est important de le lire donc il faut
aller à électrochimique versaillant
j'ai pas les dates mais c'est bien parce
que c'est comme ça vous allez sur le
site pour pouvoir voir les dates on peut
aller sur le site du département et et
trouvez voilà tous les événements dont
on parle voilà quand on aura terminé la
Commission et puis que ce sera passé au
conseil pour la détermination des
subventions les dates seront mises bien
sûr pour ça on a les journées Maurice
Ravel Maurice Ravel c'est quand même un
voisin c'est à mon format Maurice c'est
juste à côté de chez moi oui bien sûr il
a sa maison
et donc ça aussi c'est un musée qui
enfin amusé pardon un festival qui date
de très très longue année ça fait
nombreuses années
si on a envie d'écouterravel magnifique
ça vaut le coup surtout dans un endroit
aussi magique exactement et puis on a
une biennale aussi de photos sur
Rambouillet qui est aussi quelque chose
de très intéressant c'est encore autre
chose photo oui c'est dans la bergerie
et ça c'est aussi un festival de très
grande importance ça vaut la peine d'y
aller comme ça on découvre la bergerie
on découvre tous l'espace au niveau de
Rambouillet et puis il y a des photos
vraiment fantastique ça vaut la peine et
puis on pourrait parler de théâtre un
tout petit peu on a les petites scènes
de la Guyane
alors ça c'est un petit festival mais
avec beaucoup de charme je vais y aller
cette année j'avoue que voilà je suis un
petit peu en retard
de théâtre qui est de très bons tons
alors enfin je veux dire de qualité
excellente puis demande pas un budget
colossal mais qu'on souhaite accompagner
parce que il y a pas beaucoup de
festivals de théâtre et donc finalement
on s'est dit bah les accompagner
et on a blouse sur scène bien sûr qui
n'aime pas le blues qui n'aime pas le
jazz enfin moi j'adore en tout cas et
sur scène ça fait rêver quand même de
pouvoir aller au bord de l'eau pour
écouter du jazz si plutôt c'est plutôt
une bonne chose on en a plein
de plaisir qui s'appelle escale
d'ailleurs je vois pourquoi je le ventre
qui a plus de maintenant presque 17 ans
d'existence et qui accueille 10 000
personnes sur une journée et donc on
présente des arguments que ce soit la
musique l'exposition La culinaire je
vous y invite c'est le mois de juin vous
venez du monde de la culture avant de
avant d'être mère et et c'est compliqué
parfois quand on a dépassé de l'autre
côté de voilà il faut décider il faut
faire des choix on aimerait aider tout
le monde suppose
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué parce que
quand on a été de l'autre côté et qu'on
a fait des demandes de subvention et que
c'était si difficile et j'avoue que
quand je suis arrivée beaucoup de mes
collègues m'ont dit oh ben c'est super
quelqu'un du spectacle qui vient là ça
va beaucoup nous aider
j'essaye de faire un maximum mais c'est
vrai que quand je suis arrivée il y a eu
un changement de mode de fonctionnement
il y a eu aussi des réflexions
différentes ce qui fait que voilà
c'était un petit peu difficile au départ
de d'expliquer que tout n'est pas
extensible au niveau des finances qu'on
est obligé de faire des choix d'avoir
une feuille de route comme je disais
tout à l'heure et parfois j'ai eu un peu
de réticence bon maintenant nos appels à
projets
oui d'ouvrir davantage à votre
partenaire et puis d'autre part on nous
dit aujourd'hui dans d'autres instances
que ce soit l'état la région ils disent
qu'on a eu beaucoup de courage devait
être en place des appels à projet que
eux-mêmes souhaiteraient le faire donc
finalement on a montré la route il y a
un dernier mot on parlait du festival
des bureaux des quartiers de la
politique de la ville c'est vrai que la
culture c'est aussi un lien important
pour
pour ces quartiers pour certaines
populations de les amener justement à la
culture ça c'est fondamental aussi oui
alors il y a des aides de départementale
très importante heureusement dans le
cadre des politiques de la ville on a
aussi des aides de complémentaires je
parle en tant que mère surtout et on se
rend compte que il y a beaucoup
d'accompagnement avec les cités
éducatives mais également avec ce que
met en place le département avec le
passe plus c'est quelque chose qui
accompagne énormément les jeunes et on
peut ça coûte pas forcément très cher
quoi voilà pas du tout au contraire
c'est de l'argent qui est apporté à nos
à nos partenaires mais qui permet à des
jeunes et bien d'accéder à la culture et
où on se porte bien sûr mais c'est
quelque chose de très important le
département est très très vigilant et
actuellement mais aussi en place des
nouveaux projets dont on vous parlera
certainement dans quels sont j'espère
bien
parce qu'il y a des choses qui sont en
cours et qui sont en réflexion
aujourd'hui et qui vont vraiment dans le
sens de l'accompagnement des quartiers
en politique de la ville où on fait déjà
énormément de choses merci beaucoup
merci j'espère qu'on va donner à peu
près quelques quelques clés comme ça
puis oui n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur
le site du département exactement c'est
très important il y a tout et surtout
appeler le département on vient vous
voir on vous accompagne et on fait tout
pour vous accompagner vraiment dans le
sens fort merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]